hi everyone sal here from khan academy
welcome to the homeroom live stream
today we're going to be doing an ask me
anything about anything so if you have
your questions start to put them in the
message boards underneath this video on
facebook or youtube and we have team
members who are going to surface the
questions to me and uh feel free to be
very creative with your questions i'm
happy to i'm hard to offend or surprise
uh but before we get into that i will
make my standard announcements first of
all a reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization we can only
exist through philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself so if you're in
a position to donate please think about
going to khan academy dot org slash
donate and any amount ten dollars twenty
dollars it all makes a difference it
allows us to provide a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere at least
be part of that
the other announcement is you know i
want to give a special shout out to
several organizations that have helped
khan academy especially through the
covid crisis we were already running
into deficit before the crisis and then
our server costs have gone up
dramatically because our traffic is
almost 3x of what we saw during normal
times we've been trying to accelerate
content areas and various programs for
teachers and parents and so special
thanks to bank for america google.org
att fastly and novartis and many others
amgen foundation many other foundations
and organizations that have supported
khan academy over the years but
especially during the covenant crisis to
make sure that we can support all of you
all as much as possible
also make an announcement if you've
enjoyed these
live streams
you can also access them as a podcast i
think a subset of them and maybe edit a
little bit as a podcast and that has the
benefit of you not having to see my face
uh which might be more pleasant and and
you could drive uh so encourage you uh
to take a take a look at that i'll also
make you know and i see the question
starting to come in and before i start
getting to them
i i'll make a couple of announcements
just in case all don't know about it
since we are into the back to school
period
khan academy has a ton of resources for
you
hopefully you're aware of you know we
have pretty much every subject in grades
starting from pre-k
through the core of college we have khan
academy kids that goes from a third
grade or a pre a three-year-old to six
or seven-year-olds and that's reading
writing math and social emotional
learning everything i'm talking about is
free not for profit paid for with those
donations which hopefully some of y'all
are making
we have math that obviously goes well
into elementary middle high school and
then college statistics calculus and
even multi-variable we're about to
launch a multi-variable calculus that
has exercises in the next in the next
couple of weeks we've also launched
something called get ready for grade
level courses this is an issue that's
always existed but it's frankly a bigger
issue now because of covid
that as kids come into the new school
years as you come into the new school
year how do you know that you're ready
for whatever course you're getting into
you can go to the get ready for let's
say sixth grade course or the get ready
for algebra course take the course
challenge if you do well on it that
means you're pretty much ready if you
don't do well on it then you can finish
and get mastery on that get ready for
grade level course it'll accelerate you
through the stuff you know by taking
course challenges and unit tests but the
other stuff you can make sure you have a
strong foundation which you can do in
parallel to the grade level course or
you can do before so that you you have a
really strong foundation another project
i want to make sure that everyone knows
about before i jump into the questions
there's a side project that i hope one
day might become part of khan academy
but today it is a side project it's
called
schoolhouse.world and this is a place
where you as a student or your children
or anyone you know can get free
live group tutoring from really well uh
from accomplished and really good tutors
of frankly all ages and if you want to
be a tutor you can also apply to be a
tutor and right now we have more tutors
and less students so there's actually
several thousand slots of where you can
get free tutoring especially we're
starting in high school math and then in
the next few weeks we're probably going
to expand to k through 12 math the
sciences we're also doing sat and math
now we'll probably do sat tutoring in
english in the next few weeks as well so
of any age if you're a parent of a
younger child say 13 or under you would
be the person who would have to go
register on schoolhouse.world but
encourage as many folks as possible to
go there you can kind of get on the
waiting list but there's a lot of
openings for several thousands of folks
right now uh to start getting some free
group tutoring sessions
live so with that i'm happy to start
taking some uh questions so let's see
from youtube
80 videos there's actually two questions
how can we get interested in studying on
our own and 18 videos is also what is
the easiest ways to get interested in
math
well um
i'll try to get you interested right now
you know every subject that you look at
in school sometimes when you're in
school you're like oh this is being
forced on me i have to do this for the
test and when you think of it that way
it loses sometimes it sometimes might
lose its joy but when you appreciate
that as as you know as sentient beings
in this universe one of the things that
makes humans humans is that we're trying
to understand the universe we're living
in and we're trying to understand how do
we interact with this with society in
the universe and and and and have happy
productive lives and so the other day
knowledge is really the underlying thing
that gives us clues about the mystery
we're in and how we can interact with it
and the things that you see in your
textbook or on khan academy or wherever
else this is human knowledge that has
been accumulated
over thousands of years people have
often times dedicated their entire lives
to one paragraph of your textbook and
you get to just see the answer the
solution or the understanding right
there and so as you read your textbook
or as you learn in class or as you're on
khan academy remind yourself what how
lucky we are to have this knowledge and
then also never be satisfied with just
you know memorizing the formula
or figuring out how to pattern match for
the test
always think about how does this connect
to other things that i know how does
this
connect to my understanding of the
universe you know when you if you're in
chemistry class and you're learning
about
atoms and you know electrons and protons
and neutrons realize wow these are
mental constructs that we as human
beings have formed to to predict what
happens when these substances interact
with each other in different conditions
but what really is an atom like you know
if we can't see it if we can't touch it
we can measure in in indirect ways you
know what does that really mean and you
know what is real if an atom is mostly
open free space um if most of what we
see around ourselves is actually vacuum
and what i think is solid is actually uh
really coulomb repulsive forces between
atoms that don't want their electrons to
overlap with each other when you start
to you're like wow this is starting to
explain the philosophy of the universe
and you know you can do that in any
science you know the humanities give us
clues about the human condition and who
are we as as beings and math you know
there's a special place for math where
that's the purest way of understanding
the universe if we ever come in contact
with aliens that try to communicate with
us math is going to be our initial touch
point where we are able to establish
that the other party is actually a
sentient intelligent being uh is
probably with math will probably try to
you know give them prime numbers or
something like that to or they would
give us prime members to see whether
we're actually you know uh intelligent
or some other type of universal
mathematical problem so you know i find
math to be the purest most abstract
everything else
is kind of clouded by our senses
you know even things like physics and
other sciences it's really all that we
can perceive and measure but math has a
purity to it that gets kind of a at a
much at a much
at a much deeper state and and you know
there's there's definitely some concepts
out there in math that i generally think
will blow your mind many of y'all seen
that video where i talk about euler's
identity where e to the i pi is equal to
is equal to negative one and that's one
of those things that it just gives you
chills when you realize that e comes
from notions of continuously compounding
interest the derivative of a function
that's itself it comes out of
some natural phenomenon exponential
growth
pi obviously the ratio of the
circumference of the diameter of a
circle i is a number that in some ways
constructed by mathematicians to have a
what could be the next square defined as
the square root of negative one and the
fact that there's a very strong argument
that e to the i pi these things that
come out of completely different domains
equals negative one it's
it's chilling it's like there's some
hidden pattern to the universe that um
we're just getting glimpses of you know
some people have called euler's identity
proof of the the proof of the existence
of god you know i i'll leave it up to
you to to think about whether you
whether you feel that or not uh but i'm
just trying to make you appreciate that
you know the tools that you're building
in math class are going to open up a
universe uh that will give you that will
be awe inspiring and they will give you
skills that will help you be really
productive and useful and in life and
hopefully be able to support yourself
and support those you you care about and
make a dent in the universe so anyway
long answer you you've you've triggered
me in a good way
see other questions uh from youtube
vincer gaming when did you really start
love learning
you know i i as you can tell from my
answer i just gave
i i love learning uh like one of the
reasons why i love my job is a big part
of my job is i continue to make content
and i continue to learn new things
so that i can really intuitively
understand them connect it to other
things i know and hopefully communicate
it to to y'all in ways that are useful
in other parts of my job where we're
growing an organization we're building
software we're creating new content
we're figuring out how do we build
awareness for what we're doing there's
also learning that i get to do uh with
really great people who teach me and and
i get to learn from experience as well i
would say you know early on in in my
schooling it was kind of hit and miss
certain classes i was naturally excited
about
and i think i was lucky to have some
really great teachers and then in other
classes they didn't resonate as strongly
with me from an early age but then by
the time i got to high school especially
college i started to appreciate how
everything connected and how empowering
all of it was and then i realized that
you know some of that learning that i
was doing for fun even outside of school
was really connected to the learning
that i was doing in school so i think
it's been a journey for me i think maybe
when i was in my
you know late teens that i really
unabashedly uh become someone who uh
you know would very openly say that i
love learning because i really do think
it is it is the most human action we can
do
it's you know we've been given these 100
billion
or so neurons neurons for a reason
so
from youtube another question from
vinser
actually there's two questions here from
vincer how should you prepare for a test
and then from nikhil govinder
i hope you're well i'm doing great
thanks nikhil uh what are the best
studying methods techniques to get a 90
and above percentage in high school
so for
the best way to prepare for a test is to
be
thinking about the concepts well before
the test and look i'll say this as
someone i'm i still am a procrastinator
sometimes but when i was
young a teenager in college i was a
procrastinator so i'm not going to judge
any of you who are cramming for late
night exams or you know trying to learn
as much as you can staying up all night
but i will tell you as kind of uncle sal
that is not healthy um and i've learned
and if i were to if i do-overs if you
just kind of you know
do do a reasonable amount every day and
while you're doing it just don't pattern
match and do it robotically really
ponder it think about what you're
working on by the time the test comes
around you're going to say like oh this
is intuitive
because your time your brain will have
had a chance to really
marinate in the knowledge and you know
the one thing i will tell you and this
is a skill that i learned actually in
college
you know what i had a degree in i was i
majored in electrical engineering
computer science and another in math and
in some of those theoretical math
classes you know you look at the the
problems that you're given in say a
topology class
and you're like
okay i understand the problem but i have
no idea how to approach this problem and
what i found is if you give your brain
the problem you think about it for a few
minutes
and then you you kind of delegate the
problem to your subconscious
and maybe even sleep on it literally
sleep on it that the next day all of a
sudden your your subconscious like
passes you a memo like hey this is the
answer
and you're like oh okay yes i know i can
now do that topological proof and and
and so i learned in an undergraduate you
know essentially having challenges like
this that like we have an incredible you
know our consciousness the part that we
strongly associate with is it's just a
small part of the horsepower that you
have and i truly believe everyone has i
mean these hundreds of billions of
neurons uh that that that we have
working for us and so
you know learn to trust and delegate so
the way that you do that is you prime
your brain you
take the knowledge in you read it you
try to get it you may watch a video to
try to get some practice maybe some of
it sticks
maybe some of it sticks enough to do the
problem but you still don't have a
strong intuition yet let it marinate if
you don't know how to do the problem let
it marinate you'd be surprised 24 hours
later all of a sudden you know how to do
it now what i just described is not a
great technique for cramming because it
takes a little bit of a leap of faith
and sometimes it might not hit for 24
hours or 48 hours i'd be surprised if it
actually takes longer than that
but it's all about
creating a habit of learning in whatever
subject
but regardless of whatever time frame
you're doing it whether you're doing it
in a healthy
you know regular way or whether you're
cramming before a test always try to
draw connections always try to just
don't assume that ailee's to see say why
does a lead to c does it is it because
it leads to b first but then why does it
lead to b
talk to people about it have
conversations about it and that
conversing about it uh
also another way to to draw to draw
connections you know i i will say that
would you know i've always been
skeptical of actually group studying
that you know sometimes studying is a
solitary activity and i actually think
you should you know sometimes group
study is kind of a
not as productive as you would like so i
would always say your first goal should
be you and the material digging deep in
it and then once you but then if you
have some time and space which ideally
you have then it's a great to be able to
talk about it with friends once you've
both had a chance to to kind of struggle
around with it and then then i think uh
having conversation could be really good
the other thing i would say is just get
in the right frame of mind i think for a
lot of folks just the stress and the
anxiety associated with tests become the
thing that makes it hard for them to
take the test or do well in the test and
so highly recommend meditating we've
actually made meditations on khan
academy you know
recognize that your life is so much more
than a performance on any one test
that
you know a hundred
years from now no one's going to care
how you how you performed on one test or
another um so you know just just just
just keep that in mind that you know a
test it's important to be prepared do
your best but be in the zen state as you
take it don't be all caught up of like
what's going to happen if i do badly on
the test or i have to do well if i you
know i want this to happen uh that's
that's going to be counterproductive
let's see
there's from facebook lisa wiltrout what
platform do you recommend to learn
science terms for long-term memory is
there an existing flash card site so you
know for flash card type stuff there is
quizlet i recommend it i'm good friends
with the founder of quizlet and uh i'm
sure there's people who've already
created flash cards on quizlet for what
whatever you need to learn and you can
also create your own flash cards and
they have some really neat modalities
where you can you know
have kind of flashcards but there's
other ways to make sure that you've
essentially memorized the knowledge
i would say khan academy is a great
place
for practicing the skills and the
concepts of science and a little bit of
the not the
knowledge i guess you could call it
memorization if you like so if you go to
academy for biology or chemistry or
physics chemistry and physics don't have
a lot of memorization i would argue even
some of the formulas once you understand
the intuition behind them you don't need
to memorize them and you can see it and
you can even derive some from some of
the others biology has a little bit of
memorization but once again it's more
conceptual you know in some classes you
might have to memorize the phases of
mitosis or meiosis or you know things
like that uh but i think khan academy
really has your back and you know
fingers crossed i'm hoping that in the
next few months we have the resources to
actually really flesh out a middle
school and early high school science on
on china we actually have high school
science already but really uh take that
to the next level so you know stay tuned
we already have a lot of science on khan
academy both high school and ap level
you know chemistry biology physics and
we're building out more of the high
school hope to have middle school soon
and obviously we have college level
because the ap and the college level are
are essentially the the same day and we
also have things like econ so yeah check
out khan academy but quizlet is also a
great place to to make sure you memorize
your facts
so from youtube susanna garcia dominguez
and suzanna i feel like i know you
because you are a consistent strong
question asker on on these uh i don't
even look at the question when i have a
guest on and i see this from suzanne and
i'm like that's going to be a good
question i'm just going to read it
before i even know what she's asking so
sal asks so susannah asks hi sal you're
such a happy person but do you have any
pet peeves
well i'm i'm happy that you think i'm a
happy person and look i i do think for
the most part i i am a happy person um
but i i i have my share of you know
every now and then i've talked about
this you know i get i've been anxious on
planes i've learned to deal with it
actually that's what brought me to
meditation which has actually made me a
much happier person because it is easy
especially when you feel like you're
working on something really important
you know i feel like khan academy we got
to get this right there's millions of
folks depending on us and so sometimes
at work if you know people are
disagreeing with something or something
didn't happen the way that you wanted
you know you get you you might get a
little triggered or you go home and you
lose sleep you're like wake up you're
like oh
how come this can't happen faster or why
did that person say that or um
and you know i i've
learned through meditation to not even
let that happen um that
when you you know it's important to
engage on a problem and do what you can
um but then you need to compartmentalize
that a little bit and not let it affect
you and not not let you mull on and
until a lot of times i you know to the
previous question i delegate it to my
subconscious and let my i say
subconscious you worry about it i gotta
sleep
and and usually when i wake up the next
morning or the you know a week later you
know the thing that i thought was this
problem that could have kept me up
there's usually a solution it usually
resolves itself or um
or or come up with the solution and you
realize yeah that was a silly thing to
stress over so once you go through
enough cycles like that in life there's
many things that in in high school
college you know i stressed over well i
you know i'm sure a lot of kids are
stressed about college admissions now
you know we all had our childhood
crushes does that person even see me you
know do i have the guts to walk up to
them and talk to them you know will i
pick the right major how do i make
friends you know fear of missing out can
i pick the right career how am i going
to pay off my debt you know these are
all stresses and anxieties and did
someone say that about me but that's not
who i am i'm really a nicer person than
that
um
and and you know over time you just
realize that these things that stress
you out
a week later six months later really
aren't that important and so when
someone new one comes up you're like you
know what six months from now
if something needs fixing i'll fix it um
if there's some action i can take that's
productive i'll take it but don't let it
bother you and meditation really helps
there because meditation you know our
minds are normally just
all over the place you're like
you know i wonder if a horse in a breeze
a zebra can breed oh i gotta pay my
taxes am i a good father
that's like five seconds of your brain
if you just if you just let it you know
could i outrun a a bear you can't um you
know but even those big you know chubby
bears no you can't outrun them you know
so your brain is like a circus it's all
sorts of stuff is is going on from
moment to moment and meditation is
really getting it back to a place where
you're just like this
candle in a without wind you know you're
just still and you're not thinking and
it's when you're in that
that frame of mind you know there's
nothing you you know this this can apply
in any religion you know in every
religion there's been
mystics who have gotten
well steeped in meditation and they've
been able to steal their mind and when
you still your mind
you start appreciating how how silly
some of the things that you were taking
seriously
are and you start appreciating that you
know the end of the day all you really
are are you know that you can really
claim you are is a consciousness and
even you know these notions of your
identity and your name and your your
physical persona these are just part of
material reality these are these are and
some of these things are are constructed
you know your your persona your
your your place in society your
connections and that liberates you a
little bit and i say the other um the
reason i'm happy is i think i've just
been very lucky in life you know i get
to do what i love uh you know i have a
wonderful wife wonderful kids i get to
you know work with wonderful people and
i think you know there's nothing like
that that that you know i i i guess
makes you click your heels uh on the way
to work which is now in my house
all right so facebook mohammed ibrahim
says sal do you play video games
um
kind of so
i'm i yeah i don't want to this this
might create an unpleasant image for
many of y'all but i'm a big fan of just
dance i find it to be an incredibly good
workout um
and and you know and it's kind of a type
of video game that you can play and not
feel guilty that you played it because
it's a good workout you can play with
the kids whole family can play it's very
social so i'm a fan of that um you know
growing up i didn't i i was the kid you
know we couldn't afford a video game
system really so i was the kid that
would go to my friend's house and kind
of watch them play nintendo every now
and then they would they would hand the
joystick to me and i was like no i'm
just used to watching you know um uh so
i didn't play a lot growing up i mean
and and to something i'm careful about
them because i you know i think i would
naturally be sucked into them if if i
let myself get sucked into them and you
know i i i definitely need to be careful
that i don't get sucked into things like
that especially now i mean now i
wouldn't get sucked in because i have
i'm an adult
i have stuff to do and have children to
raise and and the you know a wife and
and family you know but but you know i
think there's a danger of getting sucked
into them so even with my kids you know
they're they're 11 9 and 5. they're
really into minecraft right now we limit
them to just sunday mornings they can do
minecraft um
so you know and minecraft and the whole
spectrum of games is actually quite good
it's creative and etc but it can also
become super immersive and the kids kind
of have trouble getting themselves out
of that that world so yeah you know i
think in moderation uh video games can
be great and and i highly recommend
just dance
um if you if you're ever on the whatever
they have the global dance floor
uh i think my my username is khan
something so you might see me sometime
on the global dance floor on dance on
just dance
um
uh
from facebook yulia
corleva
do you play chess do you like yes i
would like to learn to play the reason i
ask you about is just because you're a
great teacher oh thank you so i think
you'll be able to teach this game on
your side um so i do play chess i would
consider myself a very
good
amateur um i played chess you know i
first played when i was five my uncles
taught me to play i never kind of played
competitively i i would say you know
i've had a few um highlights in my chess
life
there was a event at one of our funders
house where magnus carlson showed up and
played a um a demo game to against four
people and
and he was blindfolded and i was one of
the four people um
and
there was a moment and he was playing
four he was playing three other people
and and he was blindfolded so i'm not
claiming that i'm anywhere close but
there was a moment where i guess his
visual because he was clearly memorizing
four boards at once he had um he made a
mistake and i had an advantage i had a
rook advantage on magnus carlsen and
that actually made me nervous i was like
i cannot mess this up at this point and
then like he beat the other three
players pretty quickly
and then i just felt his chess brain
power completely focused on me like
crushing me and i just i just i i choked
um but but he came up you know took the
blindfold off and you know he kind of
came up and he kind of like
good game you know i was nervous for a
moment um
that that's the peak of my my chess
career um and and i have to say my son
my oldest son imran he um
he's really into chess and
he has made me a lot better we we play
a couple times a week and uh you know i
have to give him credit he has a really
great growth mindset about it
about a year ago i would win about 70
percent of the game time he's quite good
as you can imagine for for an 11 year
old um considering you know i i had an
advantage momentarily against magnus
carlsen while he was playing blindfolded
in four other people um
but uh but now
he wins about 60 of the games and if if
i beat him
he's like
okay give me a few hours and then he
goes you ask about a site he goes to the
site called chess kids which i think is
great you know it's like a four dollar a
month type membership uh obviously i'm a
big fan of free world class learning but
i think you know that's a good deal for
a learning chess because that's really
good exercises and he's learned a lot
and i'm not on the side but he's making
me a lot better and sometimes he
explains the new techniques that he
learns on chess
but i really like that whenever he loses
he doesn't like throw a tantrum he's
like give me a few hours he goes on
chess kids and he he works his skills
and then he's like
dad you want to play
and then when he has that look dad you
want to play i know i'm about to be
crushed and uh i'm going to have to up
level myself a little bit no because i
think it's a wonderful game um very and
you learn frankly a lot about life you
learn a lot about
you know patience it's a wonderful game
um
uh so youtube adrian avila what was your
band's name in high school i mean i'm
ashamed to say because i'm really not
a negative person and you know
but in high school our band's name was
malignancy um it was a heavy metal band
we were enamored with names that sounded
i don't know
horrifying in some way or
yeah but that was it we actually changed
the name or we were nameless for a while
because there's some other band name
that it was we you know i i was on one
side this very curious academic kid but
there was a side i was a little bit
angsty and angry and uh
so i was drawn at that age to to
fairly extreme heavy metal um
and i was the lead singer i guess i'd
say lead screamer lead growler uh but
you know i there was a weekend where i
had to pick between going to national
academic games and and and performing
with our band which was our first gig i
think we we we were on we were going to
open for a band called paralysis
and and i picked national academic games
and so
who knows the the path not taken
uh but now i you know i still i still
really enjoy playing guitar and singing
and uh but i i definitely do much more
of a kind of a folk singer songwriter
classic rock
you know bob dylan
brandy carlyle
type of music so most of my angst has
been exercised from me
so
oh from mohammed says i use your math
videos for meditation
well you know math can be a form of
meditation
you know the kind of classic form of
meditation is kind of sit still eyes
closed and
focus on your breathing and and and and
and become still
but you know anytime you're doing
something mindfully
and your brain isn't all over the place
that that's a form of meditation so if
you're in a math problem and your brain
is kind of still in that space
that sometimes happens in sports it can
you know happen when you're listening to
music
um creating something
that's that's a form of meditation so uh
that's the first i've heard of that but
i'm happy that someone can find
um a khan academy video meditative um
so so sanu and abraham says how can we
practice meditation or teach with a
hyperactive four-year-old
i don't know i mean i've i've tried to
convince my kids to to meditate with me
and they do you know my older kids do a
certain degree the school they go to uh
the lab con lab school which i helped
start they have they do some meditation
which i think is really great but for
younger kids it's just really honestly a
four or five year old even 30 seconds if
they can sit silently for 30 seconds
it's a win and if you build that habit
and it'll become a little honestly 10
seconds start with 10 seconds and you
know give them like an m m at the end of
it
but it starts to build a muscle where
you start to you know you'd be surprised
how many adults have trouble just
sitting quietly eyes closed with
themselves with their own mind to some
degree they want to get distracted so
they don't have to deal with everything
their brain is kind of throwing at them
um so for me you know i found in the
early when i was starting to meditate
you know even two three minutes your
brain is saying oh someone you know
there's a lawnmower outside you can't
meditate
um you're hungry you know your back
hurts you know do i itch my nose or not
will that break the meditation
but then you just keep it you keep doing
it as a habit and now i do 30 minutes at
least once a day and
you know
i don't claim to be some type of
you know person whose mind is always
still and i've somehow reached nirvana
but there are moments uh where i do feel
that stillness and there is it almost
feels euphoric and time
you know when it when when my meditation
timer on my phone rings it'll chime
i feel like the tie i was like oh
wow you know i was i was in this inward
journey
so it's it it is a muscle that you can
build over time but you know i
i m my five-year-old you know we're not
like this family that's like you know a
bunch of monks and we meditate all the
time i'm trying i'm trying because i
think honestly
you know there's these stereotypical
things you want to instill with your
kids you want to make sure they have
a lot of you know academic capabilities
so that they get a good job you want to
make sure they're good people that
they're ethical that they have a good
work ethic but i think the the
resilience of meditation
uh that you get you know that's the
ultimate thing because life's gonna
throw curveballs at everyone and some
folks we're gonna get bigger curveballs
than others but if folks can
can always be grounded be present
have gratitude for what they have and be
mindful you know they're gonna get
through it um and so yeah uh i would say
keep trying keep trying eventually it'll
work
um
someone's asking me to sing
there's no time for that uh so maybe we
have time for one more question i've
been told by the team
maybe i'll i'll you know i still have
live on social media to sing that's i'll
work my way up to i don't have the
guitar here it's in the garage
uh
so let's see i'll do one
so one question ivana garbaldi says
jumping on a bit late can you talk more
about schoolhouse.world a little bit
i i heard you're starting with high
school math what other subject will you
be looking to roll out timing can high
school students taking advanced classes
volunteer tutors so ivana
schoolhouse.world is exactly that it's a
place where students who need help in a
subject can sign up for free live group
tutoring sessions and if you feel and
there are high school students
that are also the volunteer tutors and
actually some of them are some of the
the really good tutors
out there so you can also volunteer and
you can do both right now as i mentioned
is starting in high school math but if
you're at all interested in it i would
go and register and we're going to
notify people over time because we're
you know there's no reason why we can't
expand to other subjects and other grade
levels so we're going to be doing that
probably over the next month or so we're
going to be adding a bunch of more grade
levels on so whether you want to be a
tutor
and say english on the sat or a tutor
young kids learning math or you want to
be the recipient of the tutoring i
encourage folks to go to
schoolhouse.world sign up as i mentioned
we actually are looking for more
students we can easily handle several
thousand more students right now and
obviously if anyone's interested in
tutoring that's great too because we can
handle even more uh students and i'm you
know the dream here is this is covid was
the catalyst to make this happen but the
dream here is that in short order we
have tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of folks who are able to help
each other which obviously has the
benefit where you can learn your own
time and peace on khan academy but you
can get real live help but in this time
of social distance hopefully can connect
people they can build empathy for other
folks you know when you become a tutor
you learn the material that much better
and you um
you you're helping folks uh and you're
building empathy and communication
skills so encourage folks to check out
schoolhouse.world and all the other
stuff we're doing at khan academy
schoolhouse.world just remember it's not
officially a khan academy project it's a
style project
who knows maybe they might converge at
some point in the future so anyway time
always goes by fast when we're having
fun maybe i'll have the guitar next to
me next time
but it was uh really really good
questions and thanks everyone for asking
them i think we are not doing this
tomorrow but i will see you next week at
the homeroom livestream
you